[Music]
so let's talk about the regulation the
self-regulation so
i'm in front of me some notes obviously
you can see them those who are on audio
only will not be able to see them that's
fine because it makes me sound more
professional if you think i'm doing
everything off the top of my head
so at one point
you turned 500 euros into
1.25 million euros which is around 1.7
million and if i'm getting roughly i
believe that that math right that was at
the ept
san remo
and
it was 500 euro buy-in or 500
it was a 500 euro
satellite tournament into the main event
buying which was 5000 euros so everyone
was buying in for five thousand but i
won my way in because i couldn't afford
the five thousand yeah i won my way
through a feeder smaller tournament so
a few just housekeeping questions about
this how long after
that first
tournament win after the tv show
was this this was
2010 so five years wow all right
so five years later this happens
presumably in this tournament there was
less
and then crying
and running away from the table correct
okay
so what type of self-regulation
did you learn over that period of time
and then
subsequent to that oh man that that
tournament was nuts because
you know the tv show was in 2005. i
didn't actually
really turn fully professional wherever
i was living off it until 2000
like late 2008
you know i was still sort of playing
casually couldn't really get my act
together enough to to be you know i
wasn't good enough really to be living
off
poker before then i'd been playing on
the circuit now for like a year and a
half and i played some bigger buying
tournaments
but i'd never made like any like really
big final tables or anything
and this italy one kind of happened by
accident it was uh remember the volcano
that went off in iceland yeah i do and
it shut down all of european airspace i
was in the south of france for something
completely different and i couldn't get
home and someone i heard that there was
this tournament going on in northern
italy and it was like a train ride away
so i was like all right screw it i'll go
there thank god for volcanoes bless that
volcano oh yeah and then i arrived and
there was this like this feeder
tournament it's called a satellite
that night
where you know it was 500 euro entry and
one in 10 people would win their ticket
for the 5000 the main event so i won my
ticket that night like four in the
morning
and then went and played it the next day
starting at noon
and
a very strange thing happened to me
actually at noon before the tournament
started but that's like another topic i
think we can get into later maybe wait a
minute you can't leave that just give us
a teaser and then maybe we'll come back
to it i had
my first
of
a handful of completely unexplainable
borderline metaphysical experiences okay
all right i won't say one of those
because it'll be better if we talk about
we'll come back to that later but anyway
so i had a very strange thing happen
just before the tournament started at
noon and
long story short six days later it would
turn it out it ended up being the
largest tournament ever held in europe
at this timing that undescribed is what
i call keeping the audience yeah yeah
you better keep watching uh
and now for sure commercial break
i ended up being
attracting the biggest field of players
of any tournament in europe to date at
the time at least was over like 1 200
people so huge huge tournament
and six days later
i was on the final table down to the
final nine how many hours a day are you
playing i played like
10 hours a day on average some days are
a bit longer some days are a bit shorter
so you can imagine how exhausting that
is also because the longer you're going
the more intense it gets because in the
beginning the stakes are like okay i
might you lose my 5 000 euro buy-in but
as the tournament wears on and you know
there's less people your chip stack is
worth more and more in terms of equity
so your loss aversion starts to oh yeah
go go vertical but by the time of the
like you know the end of day five where
we play down to the final table the
final nine i you know for ninth place
i was already guaranteed i think 90 000
euros
i only had like i mean i think i had
like 50 000 pounds to my name at this
point
so i was already guaranteed double my
net worth for whatever happened on that
final table and first prize was you know
the 1.25 million euros 1.7
and
that morning
i did not sleep i mean i don't know what
i think i got some sleep the night
before
because i i'm somewhat of an insomniac
anyway so if i have something on the
next day that's big i often will just
not sleep very well and so you can
imagine this cranks it up to 10 and i
was dreaming you know i don't ever have
that where you've been doing a lot of a
particular thing like trading or
whatever and you sort of a semi-sleep
and see the thing for sure i was playing
poker i was like i was lying there i had
pocket jacks i had a king queen
you know just these fictitious hands my
brain just could not shut off and that
was my night the night before and i was
just like in a complete tears because
i'm like oh no we're gonna play tomorrow
like i'm a mess
i was so nervous before the final table
i like threw up three times on the way
like walking down
to the thing it was it was so stressful
but like i don't know once we actually
started playing once i got the cards in
my hand it was just like and i just
switched into this like mode
of
i don't know it was weird was that the
first time that it happened or that
happened to you
before not to that extent because i
think it was a perfect storm of like
such extreme nerves and being such a
mess beforehand
and then like actually you know being
able to play well
i don't know the delta felt more than
i'd ever had it before but i had had
that before where i was like able to
like get into the zone very well i
wonder if you just spent all of your
calories yeah yeah you know what i mean
like that tank was empty yeah so you
needed to switch to a different tank
yeah i don't know but as i'll go into
the story honestly it felt like i had
something guiding me that whole time it
was a very strange experience
and anyway i won and it was great
you